welcome back some say music can really
be the best medicine
yeah a doctor on the front lines of
southern nevada's fight with cobot 19
has a second career
the i-team's vanessa murphy tells us how
he uses his platform to spread awareness
about the virus
dr khan got you got to get a lot of
stuff off his chest
and he's not talking about the
stethoscope in the hospital he's dr
komron khan in the studio he's lazarus
both motivated each other and that's a
crazy thing it's like
me becoming a doctor helped me become a
rapper and me being a rapper helped me
become a doctor his biggest
accomplishment on stage she says
touring with the wu-tang
and on the front lines when this whole
thing started back in march
it just it just hit us like a storm
caring for patients during the covet 19
pandemic
i know there's over at least 400 450
people
that i've been able to get home who were
sick with cover 19 who are
who are going to be better now he also
acknowledges the lives that could not be
saved both young and old every time you
have to go through that process
repeatedly um it's it's extremely
traumatic
and it's like you know i really really
really really had to go through a lot
myself personally um just to get through
those times
he's using that experience to spread
awareness
in the hip-hop community look at the
numbers bro look look at all the people
dying bro
from from from copenhagen the worst
thing is when people tell me
that it's fake from instagram lives with
celebrities like fat joe and l.l cool
jake i don't see too much death man
to more personal videos posted to social
media
with his reach of more than 127 thousand
followers on instagram
and more than 20 thousand on twitter be
safe out there man
be safe out there i lost the patient
today
it was very very very painful for me and
with distrust about the vaccine
especially in minority communities he
shared
when he received it do your research on
it and make a
an educated decision as to whether you
want to take it or not from my personal
perspective
i encourage you while the pandemic is
not over
he's continuing his message from a las
vegas hospital
to social media worldwide
vanessa murphy news now